goodness gracious there's a video going
around the internet right now that shows
that alex jones
the radio host is doing possibly a
better job at catching illegal aliens
than
catching and bringing to consequence
illegal aliens
than joe biden is this video i don't
really know take a listen to this
video and then i would be curious to
know what you think about it
this video of alex jones walking around
with the camera crew
allegedly catches some staffer for some
organization
loading a bunch of foreign children into
the back of an suv take a listen
you ain't got a car seat for them
that's illegal bro where are you taking
these kids that's illegal
you're violating texas law who who is
this right here
hey you got no comments you gotta go
around there illegally
you're about to run a human being over
you got those children in there
are you you got those struggle children
illegally who are you
what's your other seatbelt your
seatbelts aren't even on where are you
taking these children
sir identify yourself who are you hit me
i'll tell you right
who do you work for are you part of this
organization
not sure i don't know so you don't know
where these kids are going
no no they they came from over there
they're not being checked for covet
so you don't know who you are call the
police we need to call the police right
now
i want to know where these kids are
going you are violating state law
alex jones first of all one of the
greatest
broadcasters of our age you know he says
some things that are
pretty out there but as we'll see some
of the out there things he says actually
turn out to be true
but i don't know because i know that
alex jones is a showman
so i don't know if this video is legit
if he actually caught them it's kind of
weird they had the whole camera crew
with him
but on the flip side of that the video
might be true
it might be real because there are so
many illegal aliens being
pouring over the border right now and
people are looking the other way
very often in our political class so it
seems weird that there's packing these
kids in the back of an suv they're not
really in seats they're just kind of
flooding in there what is it
i don't know was it was it staged or is
it just that there's lots of people
crossing the border and alex jones
is an effective communicator and called
people's attention to this
i think it's undeniable that we have
this this problem at the border the only
reason
that the video is plausible is because
we all know that this is happening
right now so my instinct when i see a
big
viral alex jones moment whether it's a
rant or it's something like this
this immigration issue i
usually think okay look he's a showman
this is over the top
this no this can't be true he said
things that aren't true this can't be
true
and then sometimes the liberal elites
prove him right they do i don't even
know if he was right at the time
but they uh the liberal elites end up
proving him right a classic example of
this
is the gay frogs alex jones famously
said they're turning the freaking frogs
gay
and everyone said how are they turning
the frogs gay and then it turns out
there actually was there was a study
done by yale and the epa that some
chemicals that were being poured into
the water in connecticut
were they were not turning the frogs gay
they were actually turning them
trans they were turning them
hermaphroditic
if anything alex jones was was too uh
reticent
to describe what was going on he was too
subdued and modest in his
his diagnosis of the situation there's
another example of this so
there's a clip during the presidential
debates alex jones
making the allegation that liberal
elites
get blood transfusions to refresh their
dying bodies with the blood
of young people take a listen
biden obviously is way plumped up i
would imagine blood transfusions
that's the most by the way that's not
speculation that's the most common thing
that elites do is blood transfusions
the queen of england the queen mother
prince charles the the democrats
uh joe biden uh is not on record doing
it but we know the clintons do it
we know that al gore does it you know
all this goes on
so the plumping him suddenly looks like
he gained like five pounds that's a lot
of blood in my experience
and the rosing of the cheeks i mean he
gained he's been missing like a week he
gained a lot of weight
and i would imagine methamphetamine is
well but i would imagine it's blood
that he was getting uh that's my expert
analysis of that
that's the expert analysis right oh alex
that's so crazy what are you talking
about
rich elites get the blood trends no
newsweek what are you
newsweek headline can blood from young
people slow aging
silicon valley has bet billions that it
will
so just to be clear uh no no
proof here that uh joe biden or the
royal family
or these people are plumping themselves
up on the blood of the young
but there is evidence that these rich
liberal elites
want to take young people's blood and
put it in their bodies
and presumably plump themselves up with
it
al you've got to give the guy credit
when he
when he in his sort of over-the-top
manner i guess sees something
this seems like a bad idea to me the the
putting the blood of young people into
old rich people
is presumably you're not putting rich
young people's blood into rich old
people
i presumably there's going to be some
financial incentive here so you get paid
for your blood or something so it's just
these rich old people
buying the blood of poor young people it
seems
weird to me if your entire
goal in life is just to extend your
physical
existence to try to beat mortality
well one that seems like a fool's errand
to me but it's pretty ghoulish
i mean it's basically the most ghoulish
thing i can possibly
imagine and it comes from this
state religion that we have which is
secular progressivism
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you